Hey, Jeremy.
What are you working on?
>> Just developing.
>> Really?
>> Yeah, it's actually going super well.
Thanks for all the help with Gradle.
>> Sure.
>> Yeah, it's really helped
me keep my bill organized.
>> Well, I'm glad to help.
>> You know what?
I think I'm actually finished.
Well, nice work.
>> Yeah, my plans for
world domination are complete.
Thanks, Mark.
Oh hey, do me a favor though,
will you meet me at the radio tower and
bring along some chicken wire,
a frying pan, and two AA batteries?
>> Sure.
>> All right.
Thanks, Mark.
You're the best.
>> Sure.
Wait, what?
Well, I hope you learned
something in this course.
Familiarity with Gradle
will serve you well,
no matter where your
development journey takes you.
Testing and build automation
make even the largest projects
easy to create and deploy.
This is Mark from Gradle, signing off.
Jeremy, what'd you mean
by world domination?
What did you build?